In Hawaii this week, people have been filming the
huge flows coming out of the Kilauea volcano on
Hawaii's big island.
This is actual footage of lava approaching a car that
people have been talking about.
It's really, really pretty intense.
Now that's just a very short clip.
We got our hands on the longer version.
Let's check it out.
(ringing)
[Man] Hey, Alex, it's Lonnie from Uber.
I'm outside your house right now.
(laughter)
The white mustang
next to the lava flow.
(laughter)
Okay, I can wait like two more minutes.
Alex, it's Lonnie from Uber, you coming out?
You're canceling it?
Okay, well, we have to charge you.
You can take that up with Uber.
Fine, you give me one star.
I give you one star.
(rings)
Hey, Sarah, it's Lonnie from Uber.
I'm coming through the gate now.
White mustang in a blob of lava.
(laughter)
(applause)